Hey look here with the outdoor boys
YouTube channel and today I'm gonna be
restoring a hog splitter this folks is
what we call a hog splitter it is a
two-handed meat cleaver used for you
guessed it splitting a hog carcass
they'll string it up by its legs just go
right down the center cut the carcass
into two with this thing it's closer to
a broadsword than a normal meat cleaver
it is enormous
this hog splitter is made by foster
brothers the blade is actually in really
good shape there's one or two little
Nick's in the blade a little bit of
discoloration on the blade but nothing
too crazy but the handles what needs the
attention and restoration you can see
here the handles a lot to play and
wiggle in it a lot of rust the pins
right there are rusty and there's a
pretty substantial chunk missing out of
the back more rust and see here there's
some damage there as well
still very much functional but I want to
get this thing not just functional but
looking awesome so we're gonna go ahead
and repair the edge and get rid of all
the nicks polish this thing up and put a
brand new handle on it then we're gonna
try out this hog splitter and put it to
work
[Music]
you can see how rusty the handle is
compared to the blade that's because
there was a gap between the wood and the
metal and that gap allowed water to get
in there and sit against the metal and
rust it so I'm gonna try the orbital
sander on this take the rust off I think
it'll be a little bit more gentle we're
gonna start with a 240 grit sandpaper to
see what happens
I just barely hit it with the orbital
grinder and I can see that there's a lot
of ripples in this this metal is not
flat and I want it to be flat so I can
prevent gaps in the handle from allowing
water in so I'm going to go ahead and
try something a little different see if
I can get this flatter
[Music]
not too shabby looks pretty decent but
it's time to go inside and get some
dinner so I'm gonna go put this away and
we'll pick this up again later well here
we are it's another lovely day and I'm
gonna keep working on this hog splitter
and I'm trying to be nice and careful
with this thing and not take off too
much metal I just want to take the
patina and the rust off and not much
else
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
Oh
[Music]
all right that's what it looked like
originally and this is all he got now
not too bad
still need to buff it and do some other
stuff but work on the other side first
well it's been a few days since I
finished polishing this side of the hog
splitter but it's snowing outside so I'm
gonna polish this side here my workbench
[Music]
well there we go mirror finish on both
sides for the handle of my hog splitter
I want to use a piece of this purple
heartwood it's just an absolute awesome
color the holes here are not quarter
inch they're not 3/16 inch my best guess
is that they're in metric I'm going to
drill it out two quarter inch and I'm
gonna make this English units because
this is America darn it we don't do
metrics
[Music]
[Applause]
we can see there I've ground away about
half the material on this side now I
need to start on this side obviously
using a belt sander is not the most
efficient tool for this job but it's the
best of all I got so they do with what
you got
alright that'll do it
hopefully this works
all right third one in 180 okay sure
hope this works a little off on that one
well there we go the handles on the pins
are in the poxy setting all we got left
to do is just wait for it to dry and
let's see what we got well there we go
it's been a couple days the epoxies had
plenty of time to harden so we're gonna
pull these clamps off and start shaping
the handle
[Music]
you wanna you want to do that you want a
nut there was oh you said you found it
and yeah
[Music]
[Applause]
trying desperately not to take my
fingers off doing that
there we go nice and polished that's
what we call a mirror finish right there
my hoof it shaved my face in this thing
look at that good shave my face with
this thing that is a pretty tool right
there will your that thing well this has
been a really fun project and I'm
excited to test this hogs splitter out
now unfortunately I don't have a pig
carcass but when the weather gets a
little bit warmer we're gonna change
that we're going to throw ourselves a
massive barbecue and we're gonna get to
try this thing out but for the meantime
I've got a couple other things that
might be fun to test this hogs splitter
out on
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
guys this project was an absolute ball
and this hog splitter is awesome man I
absolutely love this thing if you liked
this video make sure to click Subscribe
we do tons of similar type videos we've
got a whole tool restoration playlist
got a whole forging video playlist check
it out I'll put a link in the
description thanks for watching guys and
if you like these videos click subscribe
because we got a whole bunch more coming
your way
thanks for watching we hope you guys
enjoyed this video if you'd like to see
more great videos from the outdoor boys
YouTube channel don't forget to click
subscribe we put out new videos every
week and don't forget to hit that Bell
button so you'll get notified when we
put out another great video